nos preguntan interrogación es
aproximadamente igual este signo de
igual curveado significa aproximadamente
igual por lo que no es exactamente igual
a 44 por 78 una forma de pensar en esto
es 44 x 78 es aproximadamente igual a
que lo que nos piden es estimar por lo
que les invitó a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de pensar en cómo estimar ian 44
por 78 recuerden que no tienen que
calcular el valor exacto sólo tienen que
encontrar un valor aproximado y luego
ver cuál de estas opciones es la más
cercana a la estimación que hicieron
vamos a resolverlo juntos para mí la
mejor forma de estimar es pensar en si
puedo aproximar estos números o ver a
qué se acercan de manera que se
aproximen a números que sean más fáciles
de multiplicar sobre todo mentalmente
por ejemplo 44 es razonablemente cercano
a 40 por lo que puedo decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual o que se acerca a
40 que es mi estimado de 44 y del 78
puedo decir que es
ante cercano a 80 por lo que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 40 por 80 y esta
operación es bastante directa quizá ya
se dieron cuenta de que 4 por 8 es 32 y
que tenemos cuatro decenas y ocho
decenas por lo que es cuatro por ocho
por diez dos veces si lo que les dije
les confunde pueden pensarlo de esta
manera 40 por 80 es igual a 4 por 10 que
es 40 por 8 por 10 que es 80 y esto es
igual a voy a intercambiar el orden de
la multiplicación es igual a 4 por 8 x
10 x 10 4 por 8 es 32 y 10 por 10 100
podemos decir que esto es igual a 32
centenas o podemos verlo como 3200 esta
es la opción c esto no es exactamente
igual a 44 x 78 pero se aproxima esto es
útil porque a veces en la vida queremos
tener un valor aproximado de a cuánto
será igual algo y a veces cuando
queremos calcular el producto exacto
nuestro cerebro quiere verificar si esto
sentido digamos que pasamos por un
proceso para calcular esto y nos da un
valor que se acerca a 20 pero si nos
detenemos y aproximamos esto a 40 por 80
nuestra mente dirá oye espera espera el
resultado tiene que acercarse a 3200
algo está mal por lo que esto nos ayuda
a revisar nuestros resultados